creio que a maioria de vocês já passou
por um momento daqueles na vida onde
pensou ou vai ou racha pode ter sido um
relacionamento amoroso do trabalho no
estudo há momentos em que precisamos
tomar decisões para poder seguir a vida
esse confronto se faz necessário o meu
momento ou vai ou racha
foi na música em minha profissão comecei
na música com cinco anos de idade
minha mãe preocupada que não falava era
uma criança muito introvertida ela
pensou que deveria aprender a tocar um
instrumento
por ironia do destino
ela acabou se matriculando em aulas de
piano logo piano instrumento tão
solitário
bom aí aos 13 anos eu resolvi parar de
tocar piano por que me apaixonei pelo
violino mentira me apaixonei pela
professora e enfim o instrumento violino
passa a ser tão importante na minha vida
em vários momentos eu vivi como se ele
fosse a minha vida não parte dela
mudei de cidade para fazer bacharelado
em violino
mudei de país para fazer mestrado e
doutorado em violino meu filho lucas
minha esposa amada rúbia me acompanharam
nesta jornada
durante esse período eu cheguei a
estudar 14 horas por dia pois trabalhava
em algumas orquestras e também de
encontrar energia para estudar e me
preparar para as competições nacionais e
internacionais que me propus a fazer o
último concurso importante que eu fiz
foi a segunda competição internacional
um 2008 na china durante os anos que
estava no doutorado nos estados unidos
eu estava mil no auge da minha forma
sentindo que podia tocar tudo me achando
mesmo mas tem um ditado que diz dia de
muito grade nada pois é
pelo menos pra mim foi em 2009
alguns meses depois
na china comecei a sentir uma perda de
controle dos meus dedos anelar e mínimo
da mão esquerda
eu não sabia o que era meus dedos da mão
esquerda simplesmente não obedeciam aos
nossos comandos que estava acontecendo
era algo psicológico era falta de estudo
era algum problema técnico um bom
problema psicológico acho que todo mundo
tem pelo menos na minha profissão sim é
muita pressão no palco
a busca da perfeição o medo de errar
a destruição que notas desafinadas podem
fazer uma performance com tudo
só se o problema fosse dar demais né
enquanto a minha técnica clínica para
ver se está tudo certo tive bons
professores e também foi um aluno bem
dedicado e disciplinado é já em 2011 de
volta ao brasil fui a vários médicos
especialistas em mão e neurologistas
ouvir coisas muito duras
depois que descobriu que tinha e percebi
que vários lojistas que eu visitei
sequer sabia o nome correto da condição
que apresentava esse não sabia o nome
adequado lá em 2011 como saberiam um
tratamento adequado mas que mais doíam
que mais doeu em mim nessas consultas
eram os comentários e responsáveis como
de um médico que me cobrou o olho da
cara pela consulta e quase destruiu a
minha carreira
meus sonhos minha vida dizendo que devia
mudar de profissão mas eu resolvi
assistir
não sei se por teimosia não sei se
porque também não fazer não sabe fazer
outra coisa da vida que não fosse tocar
o violino
bom então continuei atuando como spalla
em uma orquestra e também como solista
quem ia tocar não imaginava que se
passava comigo meus dedos iam e vinham
pra quem me escutava eu conseguia tocar
talvez diante de imperfeições que não
fossem usuais alguém cuidar pudesse
pensar algo como eólicas que já não está
mais nova da sua forma mas isso não era
confesso que não pratiquei nenhuma
loucura como as 14 horas
em tempos de concurso entretanto eu
estava bastante mais do que o suficiente
para tocar bem os conselhos de tchékhov
e outros sonatas e partir de várias
músicas que está estavam na minha agenda
dê conselhos
a verdade é que nesse período quem
assistia pensava em me ver tocar quando
na verdade eram meus dedos que tocavam
sozinhos com movimentos involuntários
contraíam quando e como queriam como se
tivessem vida própria tocar violino se
transformou em uma tortura e uma
autoflagelação
enquanto eu não aceitava a rebelião dos
meus dedos tocar era o inferno
quanto mais eu queria controlar os medos
mas ele revela
então aquilo que eu mais amava fazer na
vida
passou me fazer sofrer demais a ponto de
não aguentar a minha mão esquerda
tranquila e capaz de fazer as coisas do
dia a dia
fechado se chover o violino e agir
normalmente quando estava longe dele vêm
do mundo inteiro amada é muito amada e
ajudou pesquisando na internet sobre
doenças de músicos enquanto programava a
minha despedida definitiva dos palcos
que seria em abril de 2013 com o solo do
conceito de tchékhov que ela achou na
internet um vídeo e me mostrou é
imediatamente reconhecido a mão contra a
ida dele à minha própria
foi a primeira vez que vi algo que fazer
sentido para entender a minha condição e
sabe que ele dizia que tinha distonia
focal do músico
eu não tive dúvidas que era distonia
focal do músico que eu tinha de lhe
contar sobre sua condição mesma
esperança de voltar a tocar se
reacenderam o violonista mencionava em
seu vídeo o neurologista espanhol
chamado joaquim farias
fomos então a sevilha foi um doutor
farias que entende a rebelião da minha
mão
a partir da educação do meu cérebro e
criação de novas sinapses pude tirar o
caminho de volta a controlar o movimento
dos meus medos e sabem como procurando
não os controlar
fiz duas semanas de tratamento com ele o
intervalo de cerca de um ano entre a
primeira ea segunda doutor farias me
proibiu de tocar aquele conceito de
chekhovskie e também as sonatas e
partitas de barra músicas que eu amava
tocar
porém eram músicas também que a distonia
se manifestado de forma muito intensa
então o primeiro passo da minha
reabilitação foi reaprender a fazer
coisas muito simples eu me sentia como
se fosse aquele garoto da primeira
versão do craque sabe serão do chão
então da seca tá certo sem sair e então
assim sem farías me orientava me
ensinando coisas simples modificando
levemente um ângulo de um dedo ou mesma
forma de pensar o movimento que sido
realizado
mudou também a forma de ver a minha mão
de um ângulo quem precisava a visão dos
dedos
ele me fez perceber o que acontecia
principalmente em relação a contratações
e tensões inconscientes na palma da
minha mão no meu braço no pescoço no fim
nas costas nas pernas até a ponta dos
pés
pode até parecer bobagem mas essas
pequenas mudanças para mim eram gigantes
pois faz a diferença entre eu conseguir
ou não conseguir tocar uma passagem
musical é então justamente o que era
mais difícil pra mim ela tocar aquelas
coisas mais simples muitas questões me
inquietava como lidar com dedos que
criam vida própria como entender algo
neurológico que não é tratado com nenhum
remédio acredita em tem vários
como entender que alguém não é consegue
tocar o que sabe se as notas sangue
esses exames médicos de raio x
ressonância ultrassom mostra que está
tudo normal
como entender
me senti um lixo após tocar um belo
concerto por alguns anos que pra mim
durar uma eternidade
um verdadeiro inferno aqui dentro
entretanto se a gente não pode mudar o
passado a gente pode mudar o presente eo
futuro não pode
aprendi a ver a distonia focal com
outros olhos japonesa que aprender a
abrir os olhos
pode parecer estranho mas aprendi a
perceber uma certa beleza a partir da
distonia
aprendi a ver a vida de modo diferente
aprendi a ter uma outra relação com a
música especialmente com o violino
ele não é minha vida ele é parte dela
eu não sou um violinista eu sou o óleo é
um cara que toca violino e curte um
monte fazer um som eu tenho distonia ela
não me tem tanto que nos últimos tempos
tem passado longos períodos sem nenhum
sintoma até esqueci dela é claro que têm
direções
mas quem não tem dizem que quando a vida
da limão a gente deve fazer uma limonada
pode ser mas sabe que o sabor azedo do
limão também tem seus encantos
eu aprendi essa eu aprendi a saborear o
azedume do irmão e superar os sintomas
da distonia foi parte desse processo de
superação de mim mesmo pensando sobre
minha trajetória esta é uma das poucas
certezas que tem então em 2013
eu percebi que precisava e significar a
minha relação com a música pensei que eu
seria mais feliz com ela eu contribuir
de forma mais direta com a formação de
novas gerações
então continue a agenda de apresentações
aquele conceito chekhov lá não foi a
minha despedida dos palcos e comecei a
investir também nas minhas energias para
trabalhar com formação de
instrumentistas
fiz o concurso para professor aqui da
ufmt e passei a atuar na formação de
graduandos e também da comunidade e
extensão universitária um projeto que
originalmente
dia cerca de 20 a 30 crianças e
adolescentes em dois anos acabou se
transformando em um programa de extensão
que reúne um monte de gente comprometida
e construir possibilidades de
desenvolvimento e fruição das alegrias
da música em que estudantes e educadores
somos quase 400 pessoas
detalhe todos os cursos são gratuitos
pois todas as pessoas têm o direito de
aprender música tem direito de tocar um
instrumento de ter acesso a um
maravilhoso legado construído por
grandes músicos do passado e da
atualidade
todos têm o direito de ver as alegrias
da música no programa temos jovens
crianças adultos de todos os níveis de
todas as classes sociais
ensinamos e aprendemos muito com cada um
dos estudantes que nos confiam a sua
formação musical
nossas histórias e só umas nas outras e
gente é uma história mais linda que a
outra
então o que têm em comum uma menina que
sofre de câncer
um cortador de cana o militar aposentado
um pedreiro contém dois rompimentos o
indígena que sonha em fazer faculdade na
capital e o doutor em artes musicais que
está aqui diante de vocês
várias coisas a paixão pela música e
pelo menino
a aceitação do que não pode ser mudado
a força de vontade eo momento vai ou
racha na vida
eu não tinha consciência é consciência
do potencial que esse trabalho poderia
proporcionar
talvez no âmbito do discurso até pudesse
falar exatamente as mesmas palavras que
acabei de enunciar mas não sentiria na
carne nos pólos como sou capaz de sentir
agora é a primeira vez que eu falo
abertamente sobre isso tudo não é fácil
pra mim falar falar sobre a distonia
assim nesse mesmo palco onde eu costumo
me apresentar como música de concerto
mas eu precisava falar o que eu vivi o
que eu aprendi superar a distonia e
proporcionou ser uma pessoa um menino de
ouro iniesta melhor
também creio que só um educador pouco
mais competente e sensível depois dela
mas é preciso ter tido a distonia para
que isso acontecesse
não sei entretanto se ela aconteceu por
que não aproveitar a oportunidade e
crescer nossas derrotas limitações podem
ser combustível para repensarmos a vida
podem nos dar a possibilidade às
condições de crescer e amadurecer
o momento vai ou racha pode ser o
potencializador mudanças e superações
pessoais
eu amava tocar o violino dia o diã tocar
ao vivo
hoje depois de aprender a me relacionar
com veneno de uma outra forma de ver a
presença do violino na minha vida de
outra forma
eu mais do que nunca amo tocar o violino
então para me despedir com vida aqui é o
palco os meus fantasmas e minhas
alegrias largo da partida 3 de bairro
[Música]
é
[Aplausos]